on this episode I have five New York
Jets asking me questions
hello everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode one
thirty eight seven seven on the
askgaryvee show is a very special show
d-roc once you go into the panoramic
right now editing of the office as you
can tell the altoon starting lineup
jerseys don maynard hall-of-famer mr.
Decker
you probably see the Mike Tyson stuff
and some other random weird stuff the
alley stuff but very heavy New York jet
based office is a Jain eyes office we
keep it pretty non fancy this is a very
special episode of the askgaryvee show I
I primed it yesterday I'm very excited
about this this is the NFL specifically
New York Jets preview show if I am
somewhat lucky or somehow we get to next
year we'll do it again and on this show
five my lucky number five New York Jets
ask me questions for the show so stunwin
show them don't be scared intro I don't
have lockers stolen let's get into the
je TS Jets Jets Jets show hi hey Gary
this is Ryan Fitzpatrick the New York
Jets Mike wanna ask you about franchises
specifically fast-food chains and the
pros and cons of getting involved with
that business and the second part of
that question how much money does
chick-fil-a lose and being closed on
Sundays
thanks look forward to your response
Fitz super excited for the starting
quarterback to start off this tremendous
show first of all epic beard I mean geez
Louise I mean I thought I was bringing
it a couple months ago that thing is a
beast super excited a little quick shout
out to my brother-in-law
Alex Klein I yelled at him profusely in
2009 and 10 telling him that Fitzpatrick
was better than our quarterback and so
now I get my chance five years later to
have Fitz QB this team up I'm excited to
see Sunday Fitz
great question you know you expect that
from a Harvard grad um
I think the qfr business is really
intriguing once dominated by you know
McDonald's Burger King a couple of other
players when these couple thing Pizza
Hut things of that nature what we're
seeing now is fast casual and a whole
revolution
whether it's Shake Shack pull a
different things of that nature and then
a bunch of sub brands popping up
everywhere so many of my entrepreneurial
friends are jumping into the space
higher quality food different marketing
tactics I think we're going to see the
biggest shift in Quick Serve restaurants
that we've seen in the last 50 years
happen over the next 20 and so for
entrepreneurs out there I think it's a
very intriguing business model it's a
tough business the restaurant business
is tough business but when it hits it
hits for real and so I'm a big fan of
the industry I've been looking at it
I've been looking and poking and
prodding to is there any opportunities
for me to get involved in it you're a
little fun fact any of you and Jersey no
Wine Library sits right next to a Taco
Bell dad and I just bought that Taco
Bell a couple of months ago it's sitting
empty for extra parking I've been
thinking about coming up stuff on you
would get in here I've been thinking
about a I've been thinking about um
creating some brand from scratch so I'm
looking for it you know any chef
partners out there that I've always
wanted to do a premium hot dogs or some
other random idea I'm open for business
so Fitz I think I think it's an
interesting industry with a lot of
opportunity with the biggest shift in
its opportunities it may be a half a
century coming up as for chick-fil-a you
know they lose a ton of business on
Sundays but I think for the people that
know that business and and the family
that runs it they're more passionate
about the reasons they're closed for
that and I respect that everybody's got
the things that mattered to them most
for example the Jets matter to be most
if during Sunday's game at one o'clock
at 1:47 I get 8,000 tax emergency
emergency and I look and I am told by
friends and family that the liquor
industry and the internet have been shut
down forever I could care less all I
want to make sure is that the Jets are
whipping the Browns faces so everybody's
got their own religion that's my answer
all right let's get it going Gary what's
going on be marshal marshal
question what can I do now to set up
myself for business when I'm done
playing ball Thank You Brandon first of
all thank you so much for helping me
curate this tremendous show I'm super
excited as you can tell by wearing your
number 15 t-shirt you're going to
rebrand 15 in green the proper way I
like that a juror um there's a lot of
things you could be doing to prepare for
life after football I think a lot of it
has to be to do around networking with
the right people in the business world
or any other place you want to go into
especially when you have celebrity
status as a as a football player you can
leverage that during your time it's
amazing I've watched this happen with a
lot of my athlete friends it's amazing
the level of leverage lost the second a
player stops playing from literally the
day before it's incredible and so while
you're active being in New York market
is a tremendous opportunity you have a
huge opportunity to to leverage that
because you have access to so many
individuals so what I think you have to
do is reverse engineer what you want to
accomplish and and then start networking
and using that celebrity to get access
to people and start learning and start
executing start making real
relationships so they're tangible
relationships and they're not built on
oh I want to hang out with my favorite
football player or football player
they're there the real relationships
post football where you actually have
that rapport and you go into business or
motivation or nonprofit or whatever it
is your driver and so there's that
Branden I'm going to give you a little
prediction here this is one of the
toughest secondaries you're facing this
Sunday with Cleveland which concerns me
but I still see six catches for 89 yards
and a and a sit back touchdown
his roll out roll Gary
Eric Decker Decker I know how can
athletes use social media to expand upon
the brand Eric I think one of the
biggest first of all super pumped you
and be marshalled tag team I love this
that's receiving core we've had in a
long time probably since 98 uh you know
I think I think athletes need to engage
with their fans a lot more you know just
pushing out like come to you know my
nonprofit event you know buy my Jersey
support my friend
you've obviously have a celebrity spouse
as well so bring exposure at her stuff
like all old celebrities not just
athletes always pushing pushing pushing
pushing like you know come and see
myself do this stuff coming to do this
for me do this for me how about doing
something for them the amount of people
Eric right now on Twitter that are
saying Eric Decker can't wait Eric
Decker did it a lot of people saying
Eric tractor you're so hot you know why
don't you engage with some of those
people and literally just use Twitter
video like I love to use grab your phone
go to Twitter reply at the I'm gonna do
it right now you know what you rock I'm
gonna do it right now let's just
randomly pick somebody this is the way
to do it right you'll probably edit and
do whatever you're doing here we go I'm
just hitting notifications boom there we
go let's see who says something here
real d-roc said something do you reckon
ever let's define something here all
right let's just keep going just
scrolling a lot of read branding let's
see if somebody says hello dustin riddle
gary vee have a great day great so i hit
the reply button I hit the camera in the
bottom left corner I hit the camera on
top right corner I switch at the camera
mode I flip it to selfie mode and now I
forgot the goddamn guy's name some of a
[ __ ] let's sex it out let's go back
done
Dustin got it all right Dustin here we
go here we go hmm hmm yeah so what
happens when you do it live Dustin video
camera first
Dustin's garyvee I appreciate that
brother I hope you have a wonderful
wonderful weekend thanks man
and that's it and now I'm actually
bringing value to Dustin Eric the amount
of people that when you wave to them in
the crowd or you throw them a glove or
you say hey they go crazy you can scale
that you can scale that on social and
create real depth you know real depth
the amount of people that I've done
those videos for and just engage with
and said hey that then the next day go
out and buy Jab Jab Jab right hook or
when Jason Glen number 58 special teamer
gave me some naps at a Jets Patriots
game when I was on the field and just
said hey the next day I went and custom
ordered his Jersey had a hundred bucks
that is what's happening it's very easy
for you to get into the trenches of
Twitter at scale and engage with your
fan base and I highly highly recommend
that let's do it good hey Gary Mario
Davis double Dan backer New York Jets
number 56 aka double D coming at you I
got a question when it comes to startup
companies is it better to use your own
capital raise money for what to take out
alone give me back one announcer please
sir I love it tomorrow you got a couple
fun facts for you number one you may be
56 now but you're looking at a human
being probably the only one who has a
number 49 Demario Davis because when you
were drafted out of the third round by
us two funny things happened one I
ordered your Jersey immediately because
I knew what double D was gonna bring to
the table
cuz I've got a story that you don't know
which is I've got some friends in that
team that I don't like as much called
the Patriots and when you were drafted
in their draft room they were really sad
and scared which excited me because I
knew double D was gonna bring it to the
New York Jets you know you didn't know
that huh Stefan you didn't know that
double D but I did now let me answer
your question all three work they all
can work again if you're asking for
selfishly for you if you've got some
startup the ideas you know I think that
raising money is the way to go because
you can it'll come to you easy
you have the leverage of your notoriety
and things of that nature and so that's
that's the route and really for a lot of
people if you're able to raise money the
terms raising money are so attractive
these days that you can mitigate a
little bit of your risk without using
your own money and loan you're on the
hook and interest and things that nature
so to me it's raised money first closely
followed by using your own money
especially if you can afford it and
especially if you really believe in it
but the reason I think raising money
instead of your own money is a little
bit more attractive is because the
people that you bring money from there's
dumb money and there's smart money by
bringing smart money people that write
fifty hundred thousand dollar checks
that happen to be in that business or
that can happen to have leverage to get
you your first five clients right if
you've got a wine and spirits or social
media startup I'm a great investor
because I've got clout in those worlds
so I've got my money on the line right
and I'm gonna go use my power to bring
opportunity for it so smart money is
really the most attractive then dumb
money just the money for the money
versus your own money becomes a debate
based on your own financial situation
third is the banks third Thank You Nick
hi Garrett this is Nick Faulkner yes I'm
just wondering what are the few things I
can do now to prepare for business after
football so Nick I think you know
similar to be Marshall there's a lot of
networking aspects but the other thing
that I think you could be doing
especially during the offseason let's
talk about another thing real quick
right now we're very focused on the
Brant Browns and the season guys all of
you let's not worry about these answers
we can focus on that in February March
and April let's get really focused on
football but I got you back coach Bowles
but uh Nick I think one of the things
that you can do is start becoming a
practitioner and an executor in the
place that you're passionate about you
know you're gonna kick out a football at
some point and what's gonna happen is
you're going to want to go and do
something being good at that actually
matters right like actually like if
you're passionate about music or you
want to start a music app you know
downloading all the music apps reading
about music apps engaging with people
and talking to them about music apps to
me the advice here and for everybody
who's watching
vaynernation is listen way too many
people want to be something versus
actually putting in the work to be a
practitioner for an end and a lot of you
are jumping into things by raising money
by quitting your jobs by putting your
other asset the one you have the most
which is your time between 7:00 p.m. and
2:00 in the morning into something
without prepping for it the amount of
people that are jumping into the cold
pool of business without warming up
right the amount people just hitting the
court without stretching the amount of
people that are just jumping into
business doing no prep work by the time
I was 22 years old to run my dad's
business I'd done eight years of real
prep work right by the time I started
vaynermedia you know this thing it's not
winning by accident it's winning because
2006 2 3 4 years of just being a social
media personality and practitioner 15
years being businesslike like I put in
the work you've got it he can't run a
marathon cold all five these phenomenal
athletes they didn't just roll out of
bed you know this Sunday morning coming
up and play they've been in mini camp
they've been in training camp
they've been prepping they've been
studying the film I hope you guys are
studying the film they've been getting
ready for this game and so way too many
of you entrepreneurs and Nick the thing
that way 20 athletes take for granted
and celebrities and other people that
transition other things is like cool you
just think because you were a great
kicker in the NFL you're gonna be a
great entrepreneur it's just not how it
works you've got to put in the work and
so I would say to you and this is why I
broke up you and Brandon's questions
similar points of view Brandon and Nick
it's about not only networking you're
having relationships but then you've got
to be able to bring tangible skills to
the table and so that's what I would be
doing Nick now getting deeper into your
studies on the thing that you want to be
doing post NFL guys I mean like listen
there's just no there's no better show
for me than what just happened five
amazing New York Jets asking questions
for the show so now I'm going to go into
my prediction part and give you a
prediction for this Sunday like I'm
going to do every week prior to the game
you know depending on Thursday Friday
Wednesday depending on how many shows
them I'm taping that week and then
going to give you the season prediction
which is the big one the sad thing is
this show hasn't been going around that
long and so you don't know that for the
last four years NFL seasons I have been
very pessimistic and have predicted the
Jets not to make the playoffs and very
worried and you know five and eleven six
and ten I've been very down very
concerned about many different things
and so a lot of you don't know that I'm
not normally it's the one place where
I'm not a true optimist you know it's
been thirty five three years of tough
pain being a Jets fan and so however I
have newfound light for this season I'm
very excited you know the if the
offensive line holds if the safety plays
as strong as I'm hoping we've got some
youngsters prior we need a lot from you
you know but when I look at look at that
whole situation
Sheldon coming back hopefully in four
weeks maybe it's six or eight depending
what the NFL does you know big cat 92
like one time Shaun Ellis now Leonard
Williams looks like a beast I'm very
optimistic Moe as strong as gets you got
Batman and Robin in the secondary the
Batman and Robin of the receiving core
I'm obsessed with Quincy number 81 HVAC
tight end stuff there's a lot stuff
devin Smith we're about to see what he
can bring to the table I'm a big
believer in the coach bowls fitzpatrick
demeanor and i think chris ivory is one
of the grossly underestimated running
backs in the NFL and the special teams
could do a little something I'm excited
about that Chris number 17 like what
you're doing and so I think that the New
York Jets are going to go ten and six
and here's why because I think the
Buffalo Bills are the most grossly
overrated team in the NFL everybody's
buying into the hyperbole I am
completely blown away by people's belief
that they're going to the playoffs and
they're gonna win nine or ten games it's
a five and eleven team they stink and
we're gonna find those openings of
victory we're gonna lose some games
along the way I know that most people
have the Jets at five and eleven six and
ten I know the most optimistic have us
at nine and seven I'm going all-in on
this team I feel it I feel it in a big
way ten and six and with that this
Sunday the Jets go out and beat the
Cleveland Browns who have not won an
opener since I think 2000
or nineteen to seven and that's my
predictions for the season I'm excited
we will track it along the way I
recognize that I've put myself out there
but I believe baby I believe statement
of the day in that statement I'm
tweeting it a little bit for this
weekend I want your favorite teams
prediction record for the season just to
see where you guys are at and I'd love
to see your statement I hope you enjoyed
this show as much as I did
J ETS Jets Jets Jets you keep asking
questions
jet players and I'll keep answering them